[Musique]
annie cordy vous représentez le
dynamisme endiablé quant à vous pour
vite je crois vous êtes la malice
souriant qu'est ce que ça donne quoi ces
deux personnages se rencontrent
je vais envoyer nous sommes animés d'un
mariage heureux sans histoire dont et au
point de vue travail en l1 je comprends
je pense que ça le résultat sera beau on
espère je représente le risque mais moi
je représente les comics la malice mais
elle est ramenée sur wii aura c est
pourquoi vous êtes là ce matin on fait
ça on essaye de se passer une émission
alors on se dit peut-être que l'on nous
prend alors on est des buts et vous
allez présenter des chansons je suppose
de soi oui oui oui parce que nous sommes
eric dramatique en heure a plusieurs
cordes à notre arc et après ce soir
quelques projets et quelques projets des
répétitions il n'opère être la pétition
de l'internet whaou
comment a débuté le 28 octobre au
théâtre de l'alhambra voilà et vous
bourre il a filmé non ah bah oui
vendredi prochain film qui est très beau
de robert enrico 2 et 2
à part durant verts haricots et de
jérémy c'est un truc que j'ai joué avec
eux les lino ventura et qui s'appelle
les grandes gueules bien en attendant on
vous écoute avec eux le petit coup de
chance
c'est quelquefois la présidence qui vous
envoie
une petite chance dans ton histoire jeu
sur d'avancé qu'il arrivera dans
l'existant
on a parfois
lui d'espérance
mais quand on pense à ça s'arrangera le
petit coup de chance elle toujours là je
suit n'est que la balance
ça ça rime avec la chance au choix
d'allah moi je suis du capricorne
ça c'est beau à cause des comptes froid
lui et moi je m'appelle caroline
mais ça ça rime avec aline moi je
m'appelle nicolas moulard tout alors là
vous êtes choque pas
la petit coup de chance c'est
quelquefois
et la providence qui voulant voir une
petite chance quand on y croit
c'est sur la mancelle qui amènera dans
l'existence
on a parfois plus d'espérance et de joie
ne tente on pense aux sarthois
une petit coup de chance le petit coup
de chance
toujours là
[Musique]
à